I am c. C. A b. My name's pauline mccabe and. On the net your past.
I work in a small business called the neiman apothecary and. I've been living in this area for about five years now.
I first came up here about six or seven years ago to visit friends who had bought into a multiple occupancy up here.
And. I really love the area and. Realized at the time that i could buy.
A hassle land up here for much less money than it would cost me in melbourne. Which was definitely an attraction but.
I suppose chiefly it was really the natural beauty all these areas. That drew me and still does.
Apart from the alternative culture. With alternative medicine in nimbin probably started.
At the aquarius festival i think they were i wasn't there but they were.
Healing storms and message and all of that sort of thing. Occurring at the time in nineteen seventy three and then.
Amongst the people who say that he is following that they were quite a number of natural therapists and.
I suppose one of the this dangerous activities iran which this. Which became a sort of cool.
And magnet phonetical healing was based on beyond. You know that booth and beyond. So booth and beyond.
Catering for pregnant women and and booths it had. Were also very much involved in natural therapy. Yes and.
They actually taught themselves some of them. The midwives things like cable me to sit in homeopathy.
They were a couple of trained. Acupuncturists. And. They kind of stayed up healing. Center in name been which.
Revolved around booth and beyond. And i think that was the beginning of ish and.
With a was at the twenty's ago car pressure release more they might have been but apart from the edge.
My understanding is that there was no other sort of natural medicine. And since that time.
I mean both and beyond is still going it's been a very successful. Case of community development in health katie.
Run by. Equally by trying midwives limeade wives and mothers.
And fourteen years down the track it's to quote a vaudeville and father and organization. So simply.
With all the new state was that kind of the area where a significant number of natural therapists of all kinds
and it's become.
The whole area has become very well known for all kinds of natural medicine and that has spread from name been.
Chile's more annoy other surrounding towns. So this. Will only major modellers he's represented which.
Car practical now is to york to see. Jaimie up with the. Hable medicine. Net you up with the and.
Traditional chinese medicine which bicycling clude seche puncher and. Chinese have a medicine and. From that they read.
Many other lease unknown sorts of theory piece such as. Polarity therapy reflexology.
All cons of alternative psychological therapies such as rebirthing. Chop theory piece. In el pais just to name a few.
There are many many off them. Was. It was. So was i knew it. Well i think that healing is an instinct that.
Everybody has and. It's a very creative. Activity. And think that. There's generally throughout society a growing.
Move to take responsibility for one's own health
and a lot of the people that get involved in healing start off by healing the illnesses. Be the name on it.
And through that they develop an interest in the natural medicine so that list unless these people go to doctors
and type drugs and.
Resort to suit your and they try all sorts of on the mains
and then they might be going to get some for some training
and become qualified natural therapists in some field that interests them. Well maybe they don't.
Maybe they just continue to practice. As unqualified therapists in areas of the listen modalities such as.
You know message and crystal therapy and things not bad.
Could basically i see it is
and is sort of part of the wide a social movement towards taking responsibility for one's own health. Taking it at.
Of the hands of other people and. Learning hatch to improve your health and be healthy.
Not waiting until you get sick and then going to see a so called experience.
Attempts to manage your situation with drugs was sued yuri. Fringe was. This one.
Well basically i think there's growing acceptance of natural therapies simply because they would.
That's why they right away and and.
The ones that stick with us and the ones that are becoming gradually mainstream set. Such as car practic which you now.
Go to university to live in
and you become qualified is it as a doctor of car practic that's happened because it's valid in it
when it's better than. You with a doc's medical approach to lots of complaints and that's been proven now by. Research.
And of course there'd be no
and natural therapies which haven't attracted much interest haven't been particularly successful
and they have fooling away. When i'm trying to think of as an example we know i've lost count think of it. And.
But the mainstream theory piece you know such as him medicine.
And acupuncture and tie me up with you and started with this new day growing because they're effective.
And even within the ranks of the medical profession itself now we have a growing numbers of young doctors who are
taking up these therapies. And taking up the concept also of holistic medicine which is to treat the whole person.
To interact with the whole puce and during the process of the theory of huge consultation and.
Along with that has come the advent of the multi-disciplinary clinic way you get medical doctors working alongside.
Natural therapists and psychologists for example.
You know group practice in referring clients to each other according to what would be the most suitable upright ch.
So those things. I think you know straining it. It's fairly unique in tombs in the womb. You know struggle.
We have developed.
Well i'm a net your pet so that's the field that i know the based
but we have developed a kind of synthesis of various natural syria piece which hasn't occurred widely elsewhere in the
wood. In natural with the study table me to sin homeopathy nutrition vitamin and mineral therapy. And so you have.
I combined upright. And it's very effective and. Because of that we have. I mean there have been a number of studies.
Particularly in victoria and inquiries i should say government inquiries. And some research. Which is proven that that.
The outcomes of natural therapies that patients are very happy with the manette chapin's have the least number of
compliance to the consumer. Complaint department and. Must be trained. You have to get me gaghan.
Fringe elements we're talking about. Plus.
Apart from the imagine that adela he switched to bet there are lots of sort of other good spirit piece that kind of on
the fringe of natural need to sin. Such as crystal healing and.
Rebirthing and all of those sorts of things that are abandoned in the sea area.
Personally i think that that healing is a very sort of individual and creative in
when i speak at one end of it speak german and. That ad of the community at a grassroots level who periodically spring..
Through some individual and you theory p. And for an example of that used p.
Which was developed by a man called tom bowman dan engine long.
He was just a very in she would have body wicked and jet. Developed a sort of soft tissue chock of.
Approach to all sorts of. You back. Muscular and joint problems. And he's approach is now being too.
And it's very successful. So that's just an example and. I think that we. We always have to remain open to.
The big scene a sense of new therapies. Into the wound and. Those that are not valid. For the way and those that.
Develop and grow and. Eventually become a widely practiced therapy i mean this was the case with car practic.
For example in america. Developed by a man called palm up. And he was not a trained medical practitioner.
And spies over thousands of years that all sorts of therapies have initially.
Began with one individual who was fascinated by healing and somehow the vision kind of them.
Suddenly you will gradually if you go about your life being a particular approach. And then other people. You can say.
Ok. You get a lot of different himself a natural therapy such as complementary medicine.
Which is the tune that's increasingly being used for the six major my delicate he's also on to medicine
but that's becoming.
Kind of least popular because it's sort of divisive another chinese holistic medicine
and that's a particular tune that has been taken up with the medical profession and news seeing.
And there certainly is a growing group within those orthodox professions. A kind of.
Breakaway group which is developing.
What they call holistic medicine and we need a friend of reference holistic medicine. Is the way you approach.
The client the kind of interaction that you have that.
Instead of just the doctor sitting across the disk from a patient who is just a physical entity.
A machine made up of running pats.
That chet the holistic doctor recognizes that he's talking to pierce and with you my spiritual
and main two components zero energy fields you could say. And so the holistic. Practitioner. Not any doctors but.
Yet your therapist says well. Interacts with the client in that way and sometimes when you.
When you open up a consultation. To include all those other levels of being then it allows a safe place for food.
For example for expression of stress
and emotional difficulties which have been contributing to physical disorders so that.
Sometimes one doesn't even need to prescribe anything. And healing can.
At the very least be helped along on a new label by the person being allowed to express the full spectrum of these
symptoms not just the physical ones but all the other things that are a patent passing. The whole sale.
Extremely differ. Because. Holistic medicine is very different from the traditional.
Orthodox medical approach because orthodox made its news by stone reductionist science and that.
Developed out of the cottage in philosophy. Of analysis. We have by any.
Believed what could absolutely and irrefutably be proven and. With a net context. We that science has a d.s.
We have largely been able to prove things within the physical realm.
Particularly within medical science physics is a whole different matter
and the new physics is starting to affect us at how society really. In different ways but that's a whole different.
Masha. So the traditional doctor i need to build on the physical because that was the area.
Which was in which he's made a sin is proven. Can be proven to have predictable. Effects and. So he can watch.
A sickly move at side of that physical area. He's banned by it. According to the tenets of scientific medicine.
Of course you get individual doctors to. Real human beings. With healing.
Ability who do me that side of that room who spend time talking to people.
Particularly within the holistic medical movement but it was said there are other good.
Doctors who relate to people more widely now.
Particularly because people demand that and shop around for doctors who will treat them as paypal.
So it is extremely different holistic medicine. Use. So this is almost. So first. Yes ok.
The basis of all systems of medicine. Really is shamanic medicine which is right across the world in every continent.
Continent. By sickly seeming that. The shah. Is a sort of combination who blissed and psychologist and. Priest and.
We all started off like that thousands of years ago. And then. In areas of civilization such as greece. China india.
More sophisticated. Types of medicine came into being gradually which is. For example with her properties.
Approached healing through. Diet should have been made assumes climate change. Exercise.
Those sorts of areas and that was the western tradition of medicine food. About fifteen thousand knees probably.
Until it was i have a tune by the development of science particularly with di catchin his method of analysis.
So we have in the west and we have a history of conflict between it with the docs
and the new with doc's medicine which didn't happen in india and china.
In china they had five thousand years of an interrupt to development of the natural medicine
and it's a very sophisticated model in the western world. We had. Well. Probably the conflict started to bet.
Round about the u.
Twelve hundred when the first universities came into being
and medicine shifted into the study of medicine she fit into the university system and. There was the elite.
Medical system practiced. By those who were university trained and they will feed people who could patronize than.
Which was a minority of people and. Other than that they was just grassroots folk. Medicine and.
The situation we do along fool. The last eight hundred years with the sort of vilification of commuters to new guy.
University trying to paper when you have to bear in mind that.
Scientific medicine i knew began about three hundred years ago it's a project that for hundreds of years we had
vilification of folk medicine because it was practiced by unlimited people who didn't know anything about philosophy.
Didn't speak latin. Didn't know the theories of the guy human. It's a trap. So it's interesting.
A sociological thing that there's been that speech. It hasn't. Wristed on science to do science.
Was it useful to for them to race to pond. Through the d.n.a. Great natural medicine.
But that's changing too gradually. That's coming.
Well in this area and at least move because of the wide community interest in.
Natural medicine and because we have a university he which is.
The any entrepreneurial and interested in reflecting community interests. They have approved a three year curriculum.
For a bachelor's degree and next year up the. And also similar i think in traditional chinese medicine.
So those courses are actually approved but not yet funded and. Funding could be some ease away.
But it's really a fascinating development and if it. If we get net europe at the into the university here it will be.
To my knowledge of first in the western world. And it will mean that for the first time a night hundred years is.
The traditional media soon. We will move much closer to a place of equality with elite with adox medicine.
And that is it. A fascinating development. And so much potential. Possible because things. It's it's because.
You know strata. I think name has been very important in the development of natural therapies in the sea area.
I don't think that it's been an impetus astronomy wide because people who qualified natural therapist in this area have
try and elsewhere.
And there are very advanced stages of natural medicine in melbourne and sydney and brisbane particularly
but all of the chinese private in private colleges. No that's not true. They are now.
University courses in acupuncture.
You know melbourne and pierce i think and possibly sydney in-car practic in austria with the melbourne.
These are of course starting up in brisbane college next year in homeopathy. Classical hammy up with these.
So it certainly on the move in a strain yeah and i think that's why we're getting a backlash if legislation. Happening.
Particularly straight the therapeutic goods act.
Nimbin is interesting because of the numbers of people who practice in.
Not only nieman but the whole know with an area. That's a real sort of hotbed of natural medicine and.
So it has the potential to become a very important say into. If we get the university. Course here.
Well the politics of health are really fascinating and very complex but. It's by sickly.
Comes down to a palate struggle. Health care in this countries with billions and.
It's a vosh who compiled into that entire economy.
And if suddenly i have a nod to all the people who could benefit from my stream natural medicine was shifted out of
that system probably our economy would collapse. Because of it. Of course that's a hypothetical situation that.
I just wanted to rise that point to show you how important it is to our economy and.
Consequently the control of it is extremely important. And.
And the fact dissidents try to get people voting with a fit and.
Moving in the thousands every year it towards natural medicine.
These johnny natural therapies dissociation estimates now that there is something like ten million consultations with.
Natural therapists. You know who you are and that in fact. This is actually saving x.
Country a lot of money into hands of the health dollar.
Because it's all paid for out of the private pocket
and that it probably sized people surgery for example it saves hospital days it gets people back to work weekends.
And that's really a one on the right sort of. Estimates made of.
What that is really with but you know good research on it says control of the health dolla. He's in niger issue.
And because of the growing interest in natural therapies you know even within the medical profession. Is a backlash.
Developing.
Ever since i've been involved in natural medicine in the last twenty years we've had one to change dr another to show.
To replace natural needed.
And i mean back in the seventy's in victoria they wanted to ban us along with scientologists they put us into the same
category. And they've been numerous inquiries into.
Again in victoria where there's been the most activity there was one attempt to control. Vitamin and mineral therapy.
And put it more substantially into the hands of the medical profession
and that provoked an enormous public at cry they got more on the ages of that issue than any other issue. Politically.
And so. Eventually they realised that they weren't going to succeed by trying to squash.
The therapists themselves there was too much public support.
And also with each inquiry they got least boston actually more open more interested in finding out what was really
going on and so the best one so far has been the victorian social development committee. An all party inquiry.
And i actually did some good research into things like as standard of education. Patient satisfaction.
Reasons why people got a natural fear based on those sorts of things and it was a very fishy and. With while report.
And interestingly. They came up with the. Finding that we didn't need to be registered because we do you know.
And that was a real disappointment.
To the natural fear because we wanted to be registered because we needed the protection of a registration system.
To protect us from with a doc's medicine. But that. The inquiry into tory didn't perceive that as.
They were they would look into that. So the tactics of shifted.
We've now got the therapeutic goods department which used to be different in each state
and because of that it was the rules and regulations would you. And you know each state it was a bit of a. Shemozzle.
Really made. Into stage. Tried for example in. Natural therapies in the manufacture of difficult.
Different libeling requirements new of that sort of thing.
So they decided to make it a federal department by state can grant which in lots of respects was a good idea.
It meant that everything could be sort of standardized from one central area about.
Having got the passed into law as to who can read itin commenced to look at the contents of all sorts of medicines and.
Anything that they could band on the sort of slightest pretext. For example comfrey that if you.
Fog bucketfuls of comfrey a day you would get. Anything they can possibly banned is being banned.
And it's an ongoing price it's not complete by any means and.
The tenets that they're using the reasoning that they're using to ban these medicines is by stone. The k.
Mystery of hoops according to the reductionist model. You break them down.
Into component paths you found out which parts act even which parts are not which only depends on what they can prove
in the in the bara trees. And if you find a particular ingredient.
Which is usually the alkaloids which may be dangerous in large quantities that justifies its banning.
But have lists that. Because of the seen. Action by that. Meaning the combined action of all of its different paths.
In other words the holies greater than the sum of its parts in that when you put the alkaloids. Back into the.
Contacts. Of the leaving plant with its components. That there are checks and balances.
We mean that you made a sin and. That the taj plant has a healing. Path which is not being received.
They don't know why. Comfrey wix why. Goldenseal wicks. Why most other humans weeks there has been some research. Now.
To show that things do with for example st mary's thiessen which is a wonderful. Regenerative the liva.
But the complexities of have those who actually got a bat. Creating these healing is not understood to do.
So to ban them because when you break them down into paths and.
If you would mean is to simply the alkaloids in large quantities in a person would get you to have a list is a nonsense.
And we simply don't prescribe comfrey by the bucketful. And you. And him zero.
Prescribed in combinations with each other you really give one who want it science so. If you give it here.
Makes you without him seen it. The complex of varying active ingredients you know i need the alkaloids.
The essential oils. The proteins that are all sorts of complex. Ingredients.
The synergies to healing if it can be perceived as an outcome but how it works we don't know. So you have a medicine.
And homeopathy has forward into the hands of a group of candor scientists who are using the method to determine what we
are led to use in what we are knowledge as i see it as on trying to people you see.
Because we don't have reduced ration because we don't have university education.
That i can see to that we are not to be trusted. And the sane she reserve who. Tradition.
Which we live in is meaningless. Within the context of the science.
And so we think it's very important for us to keep fighting through university education and.